[Music]
around ramsey uh we are grieving today
a friend of mine over 25 years uh talk
radio host phil valentine passed away
over the weekend and uh he and i've been
friends a long long time we uh did a lot
of uh we've been on the radio same radio
stations many times we've been on
opposite radio stations lately here in
nashville
but we've always been good friends and
always shared a lot of uh viewpoints and
um
[Music]
of course we've been in touch with
he's been
battling covid
and uh we've been in touch with him his
wife uh the family over the last many
many weeks while this struggle has gone
on but it
um it ended with him graduating to
heaven on saturday and um
just uh uh
kind of hard to believe a little bit
yeah still a young man somebody that's a
contemporary of yours you guys came
together in wtn and both of you had
national influence
uh friends in fact i was just thinking
uh when i got the email from you on
saturday that we were the last time i
was with him and you in the same place
was uh
at your house back in march yeah we had
a bunch of uh bunch of influencers there
and uh got a picture with him with mike
huckabee i sent it to mike um and sent
it to his wife susan as well
uh over the weekend i found that in my
in my roll up there sharon actually had
the picture sharing well my wife and so
but we've been again friends a long long
time and um
you know this brings about a lot of
things um
but one of the saddest parts of the
whole thing is to watch the number of
people in america today
that are happy that someone is dead
that they disagree with yeah
on anything i mean he was a conservative
talk radio
so the number of people that didn't like
his stance on
covet issues or on political issues that
have come out and um
said they're glad he's dead i mean you
guys
really um
there are people that i
absolutely detest
what you believe
i think you're a backward socialist
communist but i am not if you die
and and you say something about that
doesn't say anything about him when you
do that it says something about you
you classless immature
unbelievable people yeah
and and twitter is particularly bad
because twitter's just full of trolls
billy goat gruff needs to get in there
and deal with the trolls on twitter but
um that's an old one but yeah
but you know it's just um
it's
aggravating and i you know i've never
i've done a lot of things it's run my
mouth on a lot of things i've said a lot
of bombastic crazy stupid butt stuff
over the years but i have never trashed
somebody that died yeah happy they died
because i disagree with them i got the
same thing when rush limbaugh died
it's unbelievable we've dehumanized
ourselves i mean now it's like if you
don't agree with me or even worse if you
say something
with some passion and some fervor that i
really disagree with you are now
dehumanized and so we're treating people
as though we've we've forgotten that
they have a family we've forgotten that
there are there's a wife involved
brothers sisters friends kids
again just to reiterate
when you do that it doesn't say anything
about no no it says something about you
it says that you're you know that you
really are a child you really are an
immature child and political people have
done that i noticed one of the senators
or somebody the other day said something
about their wish mitch mcconnell was
dead i saw that going on news feed sure
and it's just you know i hope he died or
he got covered i hope he dies from it or
something like that oh oh my god you
know even if you were so
unbelievably horrible person that you
thought that and probably all of us are
that horrible a person we probably have
thought it yeah you know
but but the fact that you open up your
mouth and say it out loud worse than
that you do it in a public manner on
social media
just says what a horrible place we have
come to
uh in our decorum we ought to be able to
argue and fuss
and fight and and take an idea and
wrestle that idea or that concept to
mask or not to mask
to vaccine or not to vaccine to block
out people based on either one of those
or not you ought to be able to have that
argument and have a discussion about
that
without absolutely having to destroy
someone
and just believe that
and it's just horrible horrible because
phil of course had come out
initially and later on recanted that but
it come out against vaccine the vaccine
and then uh you know once he had coven
was in the hospital he said he wished he
had taken it and that was his stance on
it and his family came out with a
statement from him on that um and
regardless of that but i mean the number
of people it's just it's sickening it's
very sickening so anyway we'll be um um
actually we're hosting the funeral here
oh the service is gonna be here at
ramsey in our amphitheater oh and um
it's the only place large enough and
it's outdoors which uh family was
concerned about it you know being
outdoors with covid and everything so um
we'll be doing that but uh uh on quite
an honor yeah to get to do that yeah uh
but um yeah i just think some of you
guys out there and you know what if you
don't listen to the ramsey show because
i say stuff like this that's fine
i'll get along without you
i'll be just fine
um and you know if you're that kind of
person that says and does stuff like
that i just assume you went somewhere
else
it'd be fine
because if you said it in my presence in
my physical presence i'm not sure i'd be
um
i'm not sure i wouldn't be spending some
time somewhere in the pokey after that
well that's just it dave nobody does
they don't have that
they're not powered social media digital
curry yes the the social media uh filter
from a redneck neighborhood if you said
stuff like that to somebody's face you
wouldn't have any teeth yeah you get you
know you say something about their mama
yeah you get jacked up yeah you know
that's absolutely right and so but
nowadays you can do that and be a
complete wuss and hide in your mother's
basement yes
and so uh but you don't have the courage
no to do it anywhere else we don't even
have your real name or real face on that
by the way wouldn't even have most of
the things that these people lob out on
on social media if they had to say it to
somebody's face dave they would choke
just trying to get the words out yeah
just trying to get it out the boldness
the cowardice
and the thing about those of us in talk
radio
it's our job to say stuff to mess you up
that's right and we're good at it and
yeah and phil and me and people like us
that have done this on a national level
for decades
it's our job to have the courage to say
things that you're thinking
or have the courage to say things that
really upset you
it it and we're good at our job
so you know that that's the thing